Well,
I hope so.
I mean,
I,
I think,
I know that there's a stigma attached to mental illness and that really bothers
me.
There should not be,
I mean,
having depression or anxiety or whatever.
To me it should have no more stigma than having a knee injury or kidney
infection or diabetes.
But there is a stigma attached to it and I've tried to talk about this in a way
where it's okay to talk about it and not be ashamed of it.
It's,
it's okay if you've got anxiety,
you've got PTSD,
w whatever.
It's okay,
let's talk about it.
Let's get hell for it.
Get it behind you and move on.
I mean,
just not,
it's not something that she should be ashamed of.
What do you,
when you talking to someone that maybe has depression,
do you try to get them to exercise first?
He tried to get them to visit a psychiatrist immediately and get on medication.
Like do you take it on a case by case basis?
Well,
I do,
but you have to approach it.
Everybody has a philosophy about it.
And I'm not saying that mine's any better than anybody else's,
but I do have a philosophy about it and I'm very slow to medication.
I mean,
I think you use medication for biochemical replacement.
if for some reason your body is not making enough of something it needs,
then maybe you support it short term biochemically.
But I,
I look at depression,
I,
there's a lot of ways you can break it up,
but I look at it like,
is it exogenous depression or endogenous depression?
I mean,
is it coming from the inside out or the outside in?
Is it because you're reacting to something?
I see a lot of depressed people that
in a sense it makes sense,
right?
I mean,
you look at their life and you say,
well,
if you're not down about this,
you should be,
I mean,
you've lost your job.
You've gotten a divorce,
your health is in the shitter.
You're,
I mean,
you should be down about this.
It's external things.
So you don't need a pill.
I mean,
put somebody in a chemical straight jacket because their life's fallen apart.
What the hell's that gonna do then?
That's just putting goggles on him where they can't see it.
I would much rather get them to behave their way to success and say,
what are you reacting to that you're depressed about?
Let's put that on a to do list and start,
like you said,
write it down and start crossing those things off.
Let's figure what's an action plan to change this action plan to change the next
thing actually,
and then when you start doing that,
then you generally see their mood lift.
A lot of people that are depressed or just realistically reacting to a crummy
circumstance in their life,
it's not necessarily a a mental illness.
It's just a really realistic reaction to a bad spot in their life.
Yeah.
That's such a way,
good way of putting it to that.
You weren't in a bad state looking at this might be something wrong with it.
Yeah.
You're in denial.
I mean if,
if,
if you've got a divorce,
lost your job,
your health's in bad shape,
your kids are alienated from you and you're saying,
I'm fine,
then you're not in touch with reality,
then you should be bothered by that.
And I think to give somebody a pill to mask your feelings about that just keeps
you off task.
I don't,
you'll pain's a good motivator.
Um,
you know,
I grew up in Texas and Oklahoma and I don't know you've ever done this,
but we were,
I used to spend my summers in the thriving metropolis of Monday,
Texas.
You ever heard of Monday,
Texas?
No,
it's him.
You in?
It's a u,
not n.
It's got like 2000 people in it,
but in the summers it would get hot in Monday,
Texas.
When I say hot,
I mean you look out in the backyard and your dog burst into flame.
This is what I'm talking about.
So we would be going to the swimming pool or something bare footed and you get
halfway across an asphalt road and you look down and you're,
I mean like,
Holy Shit,
me,
your feet are just on fire.
So what are you going to do?
I mean,
that is painful.
You're going to do one of two things.
You're either going to make a u turn and get your ass back over to the side of
the road and getting the grass or you're going to run to the other side and get
off the road and getting the grass.
But you are not going to stand there in the middle of the road and melt yourself
down to the knees.
Pain is a motivator.
Paint is not necessarily always bad.
If you're in pain,
it's going to motivate you to move to change something.
And the mash that with drugs to dull that pain with drugs is not necessarily a
good thing.
That is wise,
wise advice and um,
I wish more people thought that way.
Particularly more doctors,
you know,
I have so many friends that have gone to a doctor because I'm not feeling so
good and that they're almost immediately wanting to throw them on something
that's not smart.
And all the years that you've been doing this,
have you noticed like was depression as prevalent like the,
the term depression or was it doesn't,
I mean,
I don't really remember it being a thing when I was a kid that was discussed the
way it's discussed now,
now it's discussed the way people discuss all sorts of other ailments.
Is it just an awareness thing or is it just people were thinking about it now in
different terms?
Well,
I think as part of the narrative now,
and I think with social media,
with the Internet,
not just social media,
I think there's just a lot more,
it's a lot more in the nomenclature.
Um,
and there's a lot more awareness about it.
but I think it was just as prevalent in the fifties and sixties as it was now.
But in the fifties and sixties there wasn't a psychologist on every corner and
there is now and there wasn't sub doctoral licensing then.
I mean,
you,
what does that mean?
Well,
back then that you had to have a phd or an MD as a psychiatrist to see patients.
Now they have marriage and family therapist.
They've licensed social workers,
they have different levels,
uh,
where you can do independent practice.
So that's broadened the number of people that can provide services.
And some people think that's a good thing.
Some people think it's not.
Um,
I generally think it's a,
it's a good thing because I think [inaudible] 58% of our rural markets today
have no psychiatrist available and something like 50 or roughly have no mental
health professional available at all.
None.
So there's just nobody available to help people in,
in the outlying areas.
So I think the more people you can get into the profession,
so long as there's a degree of competency is better.
But,
you know,
I think it's always been prevalent.
I just think people didn't talk about it very much.
It's just something I swallowed or they took the church or,
yeah.
Yeah.